i wasn't gonna okay okay so you you
brought up on monday you brought up the
army hammer [__] mm-hmm
and i said what army what do you mean
army ham what cannibal what are you
talking about
and then yesterday i saw he was trending
and i clicked on it and then just
for like an hour and a half just dove
deep on that
and holy [__] that has to be the
craziest piece of celebrity gossip
that i've read ever i think
you think it's real though uh
i mean i think he really wants to drink
blood
i mean we watched him suck a baby foot
he probably wants to drink blood man
well here's the thing and what do you
mean and it's what
you don't remember that's it that whole
controversy the top
of the lockdown of him like sucking a
toe
no he was like sucking his kid's toe
hold on
hold on you know army army you know i
don't like putting people on blast but
you did this to yourself
army hammer is sucking toe hold on this
is what i mean you know i hate to
speculate
no no it was the other way around sun
sucks
army hammer's toe and there was a video
of it like he posted it or something
yeah
we we talked about it and his wife like
yeah yeah this is the [__]
can you share your screen or something
this is the craziest screenshot
on planet earth right here hold on
[Laughter]
[__] a screenshot dude just just mute it
mute it before you
you share it but can i play this yeah
it's it's you know it's tmz but like
just just mute the
audio okay it's muted
kids what the [__] wait what the [__]
tmz kids
[Music]
this happened for a solid seven minutes
his wife was filming it
they're just letting this kid suck his
damn toe
foot fetish on fleek dude
first of all on fleek just don't yeah
that's what i'm that's my problem with
that is come on that's
over man that's my main problem with
this snapchat story oh this was in 2019
i'm late as hell
this wasn't even no it's relevant though
because
that's what i'm talking about is is i
don't know if they're real i don't know
if they aren't it's they
seem like they're real particularly
because there's a lot of
a lot of girls that are coming out with
sim with very similar stories
the screenshots all have the exact same
style
like in terms of how he speaks and how
he writes
and also if you go through his like
social media history
it's [__] weird it's so bizarre like
he did he posted
three pictures on instagram on the grid
of like this
pig head yeah that he was freezing or
something
and it was like almost like he was like
fetishizing a little bit and like i
don't want i don't know like maybe i'm
just reading too much into it but like
it's [__] weird i mean
yeah i don't know but anyways if you
don't if you don't know what we're
talking about
i was about to i was about to make a
joke about his divorce but i don't know
i don't want to do that
why i don't want to bring her into it
you know yeah
that's fair you know she might have dip
just because like she's like damn i
really let my husband stuck his toes
i really like my son suck my husband's
toes i gotta like reevaluate i can't be
around you man
but i mean that's not the way like if
you haven't seen the dms at
the screenshots of the dms that people
are saying he sent to women
he's basically like a straight up
psychopath if they're real
i'm not gonna you know he need for me he
needs to go
on morning television with with hoda and
whatever that other [__] bitch's name
and he needs to like look to camera and
go yeah i like drinking blood
yeah i'm really into blood like i need
it to from his face
unironically he needs to go yeah i
don't see anything wrong with blood play
yeah what do you mean
it's just you know when we filmed uh
call me by their name i actually asked
if they could put blood in the peach and
they said it wouldn't play well on
camera but
okay here we can i just read can i read
some of these sorry yeah one of these
big dms i want to see
i want to see everything i want to see
your brain your blood your organs every
part of you
i would definitely bite it b 100 or try
to [__] it not sure which
probably both if i [__] you into a
vegetative state i'd keep
you feed you wash you and keep [__]
you
like [__] hell dude
even even if someone faked this and
wrote it it's like it's
sick this is the best one
oh my god that just made me so hard it
makes me confused as to why
is that even possible so hard thinking
of holding your heart in my hand and
controlling when it beats
i am 100 a cannibal i want to eat you
[__] that's scary to admit i've never
admitted that before
i've cut the heart out of a living
animal before and eaten it while it's
still warm
bro dude this to me
i am 100 a cannibal bro the funniest
things i've ever heard
this to me it sounds 100 a cannibal
it sounds like when you're 13 and you're
horny for the first time and like you're
just expressing all of it
to somebody you're like yeah i'd [__]
you here and i'd i'd suck in your boobs
and [__] like it's just
it seems like the 13 year old version
yeah that was like bdsm pulled out in
the movie theater i want to cut open
your head and take your brain out and
[__] it
yeah it's like
it sounds like maybe he just has no idea
how to talk dirty
i want to cut your head off and cut a
hole into your skull and
grapefruit myself with your [__]
brain i want to eat i want to eat them
eat them too i want to eat your brains
i'm so hard
so [__] turned on i want to put your
brains in a blender and then
drink it i'm 100 a cannibal
she's like dude what i just said yo
real talk though what i'm 100
accountable
[Laughter]
yo can i be real with you for a second
i'm like 100 accountable
you're 100 my girl and i'm 100
accountable
god damn man
thinking about him writing that out and
sending it without even
like oh my god dude you're an
a-list celebrity why are you damning
girls that you want to [__] their brains
like jesus christ there's some freaky
ass [__] apparently
dude if they ever if they ever catch
this dude [__] like
well you know now he can't even do
simple [__] he can't even go buy
chicken without judgment you imagine
being an army hammer none of this [__]
is true and he's picking up a rotisserie
chicken
it's like hot from the thing from
vaughn's it's like in the little plastic
oh like a rotisserie yeah and he just
makes eye contact with someone they look
at him and go
shake their head he's like well what's
like you know i know you're gonna [__]
that thing
no i'm gonna eat it oh yeah you're gonna
eat it oh what after you [__] it hurt
yeah surprising just get one [__]
living
sick oh jesus christ i just want chicken
[Laughter]
this dude goes to [__]
he goes to some [__] fast food
restaurant he's the drive-through
he's got a hat sunglasses he's trying to
disguise himself and he's trying to get
away from the drama
yeah hi could i could i get a number one
with
with cheese yo is that [__] army
hammer
yeah you want this thing [__] living
and breathing so you could [__] its
brains
sick [__]
oh my god i'm not a psychopath i'm just
a hundred percent accountable yeah i can
show you where we actually harvest the
meat you can just go to the farm and
[__] the animals while they're still
living if you want to
or no you don't [__] things that are
alive never mind
holy [__] i wanna [__] if i [__] you
into a vegetative state how do you even
do that
i don't i oh my god and there's so much
[__] about like
like having slaves and stuff like that
like
like there's one where he's like if you
were oh if i [__] your
oh i've it basically starts and he's
like and then i would sow you up
i would sew you back up after i after i
came because i wouldn't let you die that
would be a
that would be such a waste for a perfect
slave like that's his
fantasy is like having like a just a sex
slave that doesn't do anything
that's [__] up man
yeah that's some serious like serial
killer [__] if if it's not
like you could i don't know i don't even
wanna i don't know if it's real i don't
know i just know that these dm's are
[__] preposterous
i also know that i am 100 accountable
yeah i guess like there's a lot of girls
that say that
he they gave him their blood to drink
and he actually really likes drinking
blood what the [__]
i'm telling you i dove [__] deep into
this [__]
what [__] prove it what's your blood
type
what's my blood type no i wanna i wanna
know i need deets man
i can't i can't buy this one just out
front
it's pretty absurd but i mean at the
same time like
is it that crazy i mean we see crazy
[__] on twitter every day
they're dudes that get whipped on tick
tock so is it that wild that you know
yeah i sent arnie hammer a vial of my
blood
but this is what i'm saying wait can i
show the pictures of these pigs
uh like so you hear i don't know
i don't really know if i can like i mean
they were on instagram they're not
censored
no then it's probably gucci
okay hold on
yeah i guess i i guess i shouldn't write
it off so quickly you know maybe i
should entertain it
like so then you see this
quit eyeballing me and these ones this
is on his grid man
and then another one where he's like
syringing me there's no caption on this
one it's just like
like it's all right you know what yeah i
think maybe he hit some
some some ladies over some blood
it's [__] weird i don't know
damn bro damn anyways that's sick [__]
if
that's real yeah pretty wild army you
[__] you nasty [__]
yo killing women is your [__] kink
what is wrong with you he's 100
accountable
[Laughter]
oh man i'm pretty sure dudes like went
to jail for like actually doing that
like i don't think
yeah is that legal i don't even think
it's legal eating people
not is not legal drinking blood i mean
gray area maybe if you're a vampire
you know i mean if i like
if i was just like giving out blood you
know
you could probably drink it if you want
i don't
i wouldn't want to do that i mean maybe
i'm just saying hypothetically
maybe army might [__] bro is next
they're just [__] throwing all kinds
of
what
it's like a [__] used tampon or
something oh god
oh that's disgusting i'm sorry
i'm just picturing him just sucking at
you like a shrimp
you